peu
kouassi albert dupontel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir vous avez vu l'interview de hans
blix là c'est étonnant quand même dit
oui bah oui avait pas de preuve les mecs
12 ans complètement manipulé ça
s'appelle se [ __ ] de la gueule du
monde
voilà entier george bush est annulé pour
des mots et voilà antisociales
à un message de georges pour dire toi
même alors albert dupontel acteur auteur
réalisateur aujourd'hui c'est l'acteur
que nous recevons pour un film de
nicolas boukhrief qui s'appelle le
convoyeur avec jean dujardin françois
berléand vous sorti le 14 avril
c'est le troisième film de nicolas
boukhrief et le film se passe dans une
société de convoyage de fonds
c'est la première fois et c'est bizarre
dit les français ni les américains ni
personne n'avait pensé à ça avant alors
c'est marrant d'ailleurs ces convoyeurs
cd ouvriers en fait on rien
oui enfin c'est bizarre c'est des mecs
qui gagnent un salaire de misère pour
transporter des millions mais c'était
pas risquer leur vie
c'était parti de libération de la
société voilà actuel de la même façon
qu'il ya un président des etats-unis qui
dit que les arbres n'existe pas il ya un
an 2000 euros par mois des ti pour
transporter des millions d'euros dans
les fourgons c'est un peu un peu
aberrant ap procrit un peu fructueux un
plan anti sociale comme vous dites c'est
très bien documenté une enquête qui a
été fait par une journaliste avant et
les vraies dans quel pas tout tout tout
mais ils n'ont pas démenti la globalité
alors voilà c'est un film qui était un
suspense sur un fond sociétal
on pourrait dire un on voulait parler
que dans les voiles affalées vous
soucier table très bien c'est un film
noir un film de genre qui rend compte la
vie d'un groupe emblématique de la
société actuelle
ces procédés mec paumé qui sont armés
avec une tentation permanente évidemment
depuis que le fric qu'ils transportent
ouais ouais c'est un petit peu ça quand
même un paradoxe effectivement alors
début votre personnage alexandre se fait
engager par cette petite société de
transport de fonds
les affaires vont pas bien on parle de
vendredi lents
billets en vente aux américains donc un
certain stress d'entreprise
effectivement qui doublait d'un stress
et dès qu'ils sortent du fourgon qui
peuvent faire de leur vie et au travail
peuvent perdre leur boulot ça fait
beaucoup quand même
alors en plus cette petite société est
victime de deux braquages répétés alors
on se demande s'il n'ya pas une
complicité entre les convoyeurs et les
truands qui est qui les attaquent et on
se demande qui vous êtes au départ on
vous voit arriver alors on se dit c'est
un paumé qui a trouvé un boulot il fait
ça parce qu'il sait pas quoi faire
d'autre
ensuite on pense qu'il est un flic
peut-être qui est en train de
d'infiltrer la société pour savoir qui
organise ces braquages
on pensait peut-être volume derrière un
braqueur évidemment je vais pas vous
dire expert en conjoncture c'est une des
forces du film s'est passé 45 minutes on
sait pas ce qui se passe ni ce qu'il
vient faire et pourtant raison son
fauteuil les voûtes 45 minutes quand le
mobile apparaît du monsieur je le trouve
très touchant très émouvant et cette
fois là alors votre personnage c'est un
personnage comme ça très costaud très
musclé on le voit faire de la gym et
tout en même temps d'une grande
fragilité toujours l'impression qui va
partir quoi c'est lille et nicolas
maîtresse est assez joli c'est habile
scénaristiquement et au niveau du cinéma
c'est de dire on va montrer la force
plutôt de l'avoir à la jouer comme ça on
va garder le jeu pour l'émotion la
maladresse le pathétique le ridicule le
grotesque le pato est ce que c'est ce
personnage véhicule un peu comme le dr
sexe dans un autre registre un peu comme
dampierre d'irréversible voilà c'est des
registres que j'aime bien ouais alors on
souffre quand il fait de la muscu mais
on souffre encore plus quand on croise
son regard quoi c'est quelque chose qui
se dégage de lui qui était assez
pathétique d'ailleurs parce quand on
vous voit la paille allumé et malicieux
mais dans le film vous êtes vraiment des
cons paye tout est possible
tout était bien payé il ya du jardin
aussi jean dujardin est excellent c'est
pas du tout j'ai pas la télé d'ailleurs
je n'ai pas la télé
non c'est pour ça que je viens
d'ailleurs ses charges et magie n'est
jamais venu si j'avais une audition
avant non mais là jean dujardin je
connaissais pas et qui est très
sympathique berléand exceptionnel voire
me connaissait par ailleurs claude
perron que je connaissais sans avoir la
télévision et donc que la mariée qui
joue également dans le dernier d'un
créateur et une flopée d'autres acteurs
vraiment formidable quoi une grande
réussite de boukhrief que je salue
j'avais vu le personnage est évidemment
doux et sympathique intègre authentique
voilà très bien on l'applaudît alors ça
sort le 14 avril alors j'ai mis
antisocial tout à l'heure si vous n'êtes
pas un masque anti sociale sans vous en
convenez nombre de mes théories d'école
maternelle à quatre ans et demi c'est
quand même fort mal non archives c'est
assez c'est vrai le pire c'est vrai et
ensuite vous étiez à l'école paul bert à
conflans et ont été obligés de vous
mettre du chatterton sur la bouche pour
vous clouer le bec sfar et hambourg
enseignement vrai mais vous rendez
compte toujours cinq ans et un fumier
d'instituteurs certainement pédophiles
mais à l'époque c'était motorisés
qu'aujourd'hui qui m'a foutu du
chatterton sur la bouche quand j'avais
volé sa maison dont la c1 quand même ses
positions
j'ai repéré que ce film et je savais où
il habitait et acheter des glaces avec
quelle adresse et son portable j'ai tout
et je me rappelle qu'il avait une
coccinelle avec plusieurs fois j'aurais
bien vu cette coccinelle partir en fumée
voilà sans façon walt disney a choisi la
seule chose qui arrive à vous calmer un
peu c'est la gym
ouais puis y'a pas que ça ait des
parents gentil surtout qu'ils m'ont un
peu le calme et un peu dirige alors que
la drogue c'est le tout voilà une
relation incestueuse
le pinot noir faisait beaucoup de sport
un petit mois j'étais assez agitée à
l'adolescence ce qui vous calme est
plutôt c'était le cinéma vous passiez
votre vie enfermée dans les salles je
fuis la réalité comme vous insurgez pas
quand vous l'avez fait du vous m'avez
fut la réalité certainement aussi parce
qu il n 1 vision vous continuez au
cinéma bref c'est encore pire
voilà il y avait un cinéma au bout de la
rue et ça paie le palace voilà alors
j'allais voir mon papa qui était
doctorat même rue je disais j'ai besoin
d'argent pour acheter les fournitures
scolaires ça se terminer par un lié à 10
15 ou 20 francs à vous rentriez à deux
heures de l'après midi une sortie à
minuit des fois on peut enfin jeune je
rentrais plus tôt et puis un peu plus
vieux je rentre je rentre et et tous est
d'eric rohmer achats sont d'ailleurs
j'avais c'était la cie ne s'agit pas de
la cinéphilie
alors ensuite vous suivez l'orientation
paternelle pour devenir médecin fait
qu'à 35 de médecine jusqu'au jour où aux
urgences albert dupontel vous voyez
débarquer à un mec de 20 balais
complètement bousillé par un accident de
moto et là vous vous dites il faut vivre
quoi il faut faire ce qu'on a envie de
faire dans la vie parce que finalement
ça tient rien quoi en fait j'ai été un
peu et ils m'ont mis à pied pour un
stage
tout le monde était soulager les malades
comme les médecins que je n'en aie un
c'est vrai j'avais été très frappé par
six mois du rejoint exactement à
l'hôpital beaujon à clichy franchement
la nuit vous imaginez pas ce qui se
passe que j'ai déjà frappé je me dis si
vivre c'est avoir des émotions autant se
dépêcher de noir parce que c'est assez
aléatoire
là vous vous inscrivez un cours de
théâtre et devient un vrai boxeur on
connaît la suite il ya eu d'abord le one
man show qui était extraordinaire c'est
à dire il est des sketches comme le bac
français comme rambo et c'est un truc
que j'ai pas compris vous avez un tel
succès quand vous avez commencé à faire
des sketchs bien je vous ai dit non ce
que j'espère c'est du cinéma
hier je vais toujours faire du cinéma
mais le spectacle a été la poterne qui
m'a permis de rentrer dans la forteresse
du showbiz c'est une sorte de cri primal
mais je trouvais ça pauvre et frustre
que je voulais
faire du cinoche bernie la bande
dessinée du spectacle le créateur la
vente inexistants en attaque le prochain
enfermés dehors sera toujours au coeur
de raccord avec le spectacle voilà il ya
eu permis évidemment le créateur ensuite
l'acteur avec des films aussi important
que la maladie de saxe de ville ramsey
de trey johnson cowboys 1 vous vous êtes
très anti société du spectacle vous dit
jean le compte à rendre à personne je
vis comme gandhi
je n'ai besoin de rien on ne peut pas
m'avoir le vrai luxe dans ce métier
c'est la liberté de dire non ou de dire
oui je suis aussi franc que bush
ouais non c'est vrai vous un peu discret
voilà suffit d'être marginalisés
pourquoi pas mais je suis un peu discret
c'est tout moi je suis pas je suis pas
hystérique avec les médias j'avais
failli être un peu les jours à la télé
c'est la culture de l'ennui la télé
comme ça vous êtes une agressivité
excessive mais c'est vrai que moi j'ai
pas la télé depuis dix ans je m'en passe
très bien et heureusement je les ai pas
je vois beaucoup de films j'ai 800 dvd
cassettes gilles les bois etc
et voilà et la télé qu'on arrache à
l'automne j'ai rien à faire j'ai regardé
c'est tout les choses de choses inutiles
à part votre émission mais des choses
inutiles qu'on peut voir quoi voilà non
mais j'ai bien vu survient normalement
mais je pense que cette émission est
utile mais ces moyens procès par exemple
enfin je ne lâche pas on nous ait fait
un gros procès et sur bernie sur la
violence au cinéma et sur irréversible
gens parlent pas ce film là d'ailleurs
pas interdit aux moins de 12 ans jeudi
est baptisée donc il n'est pas si loin
que ça toutefois je mets donc j'ai pas
la télé mais le l'audience au cinéma
c'est un faux procès ce que le cinéma
est un lieu protégé sérieuse de
polémiques d'expression de déballer ses
protégés on rentre pas dans une salle de
cinéma au hasard le même quotidien
paraît facilement famille c'est
franchement et ségo et c'est un
consommateur crétins tant pis pour lui
pardon la télévision rendre ma chambre
d'hôtel crash on appuie sur le bouton je
tombais sur elle si la semaine dernière
les mecs qui brûlait dans la jeep les
américains dépecer par la foule j'étais
très choquée parce que j'étais pas prêt
à ça ouais donc une perversité eux ils
se cachent derrière l'alibi de
l'information entre la ligne
d'information et voyeurisme et un truc
une frontière qui franchissent
allègrement donc le procès de la
violence au cinéma
montcuq quoi ça n'existe pas cesser le
jeu mais qui vaut cinéma voir un film
c'est ce qui va voir sauf si c'est un
combat sort c'est hélas c'est comme ça
mais je n'aime pas ce que me fais pas
mon temps voilà sauf quand tu as bien
sûr c'est pas une attitude un peu ce nom
écoutez franchement d'abord à l'état
volontaire c'est un jour un jour m'a
coupé le cas puisque je payais pas donc
au départ et les voilà qui je me suis
rendu compte que je passais que je mens
pas ça très bien
bon sinon même un peu snob ne pas payer
le câble
[Applaudissements]
l'interview ap
d'autres
[Musique]
j'ai jamais une science fiction parlant
jamais de vue cette émission une fois
d'ailleurs j'ai été très choqué j'avais
presque envie de venir en courant
c'était quand il y avait un philosophe
parisien type closerie des lilas qui
s'appelait finkielkrault oui c'est ça
c'est un an qui ressemble car yvan et
qui expliquait en gros que les
palestiniens et ils se détestent
désespérée mais qu'ils avaient le
désespoir pas très poli puisqu'il a lui
faire sauter chez les gens j'ai trouvé
ça totalement indécent et des idées
tellement grossier et malvoyants qu'il a
réussi à faire pleurer
la délicieuse du cabinet m'a
profondément choqué j'ai presque en
visite en bretagne de prendre la voiture
et d'intervenir sur le plateau et dire
voilà parce que quand on en arrive à se
faire sauter avec des cartouches de
dynamite c'est qu'on est franchement
désespéré maintenant il n'ya pas de
politesse ou pas avoir de désespoir est
donc cette émission d'intérêt
heureusement que t'as pas la télé si
bolt n'était pas prendre la bagnole de
faire 500 banques pour mettre un
bourre-pif un mec qui dit des conneries
ouais imaginons serait pas trop regarder
un parmi d'autres donc si vous étiez un
des sept péchés capitaux vous sauriez
lequel la luxure je ferai plus souvent
la télévision mais parce que si vous
étiez un des dix commandements tu ne
tueras point comme ça j'hésiterais pas
un des sept nains simple est comme ça je
pourrais me présenter à la campagne
présidentielle émérite il ya du vent à
toi aussi grave si vous étiez en
décembre elle maintient le dernier le
101e pourrait-on chouchou est une des
sept merveilles du monde
les jardins suspendus de babylone qui
aujourd'hui se trouve à bagdad comme ça
je ferai du jardinage avec interdiction
pour les chars de marché sur la pelouse
à bravo
si vous étiez un des cinq sens l'odorat
pour m'autodétruire lors de la promotion
de mes films oh vous étiez 1,17 à le
cinéma pour apprendre quelques trucs un
des quatre points cardinaux au sud pour
pouvoir perdre le nord en permanence en
bravo les questions si vous étiez un les
trois mousquetaires d'artagnan pour
piquer déférer la reine plutôt que de
lui rendre à 5 union
voilà est un des sept mercenaires du
brenner pour avoir une coupe de cheveux
toujours à la mode
vous étiez habitant est l'un des 12
travaux d'hercule
les écuries d'augias on doit passer le
fleuve par matignon l'elysée l'assemblée
nationale là bas loin si vous étiez à
les 31 jours du mois le premier pendant
les vacances ces derniers pendant tout
ce travail bravo
si vous étiez à 17 jours de la semaine
le lundi parce que tout est encore
possible et un des cinq continents
l'afrique pour me venger
j'accueille claude perron et albert
dupontel
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir claude bonsoir albert pour ce
fournisseur de la rue albert on vous
quittons pianiste virtuose dans fauteuil
d'orchestre de danièle thompson et on
vous retrouve en sdf déjanté dans votre
nouveau film qui s'appelle enfermés
dehors
voilà alors le pitch c'est un sdf qui
trouve un uniforme de flic et il va s'en
servir pour aider une femme interprétée
par claude a retrouvé sa petite fille et
se casse sociale devient en fait sa
raison d'exister il décide de jouer les
justiciers voilà vous dit le pitch m'est
venue un soir où je songeais à me venger
du monde extérieur
c'est à dire un peu tous les soirs lui
dit ensuite j'ai cherché comment
raconter et l'espé cartoon sociale m'a
paru de bon aloi
c'est vrai que ça cartoon sociale voilà
c'est la meilleure définition du film
qu'on puisse ainsi vous le dites moi je
pense que c'est ça thoune en gros et
sociale en petit sur récompenses aux
polices man de chaplin
mais la réalisation est traitée que
savent rire jaune
ouais ouais tu la bd fil mais quoi voilà
dix films du monde d'accord on ne sait
pas qu'on était sur écoute
alors c'est un film c c'est burlesque
qui fait ma règle les choses désespérées
comme tout ce qui est du reste quoi
désespérer des étagères en rien on prend
le terreau social qui existe et puis on
part de sages nous ferons part d'un
constat campana porter une révélation
aux gens si c'est une révélation qui a
des sdf dans la rue des banquiers véreux
le vainqueur est une tragédie
par contre l'idée c'était d'avoir un
procès des grands guigne cartoonesque
actuellement pour raconter tout ça
monsieur qui a fait ça très bien il ya
100 ans elle s'appelait chaplin ouais
c'est une revisite rien les très
personnelle des brebis chaplin et voilà
alors vous dites ce film est né d'une
attitude inconsciente qui consiste à
regarder les travers du monde avec un
nez rouge c'est vous quoi oui et c'est
plus drôle que bernie bernie tu es drôle
aussi mais simplement que là il y avait
un côté il ya un côté plus bénins dans
ce personnage là parce que dès le départ
ses ambitions sont plus triviale il veut
boire manger est traîné un regard ni vu
ça frustre itude vouloir un nom était
déjà quelque chose de très exagéré
voilà donc ces nouvelles dans le mur
voilà mais c'est là la fin positif de ce
film est aussi honnête que la fin
négative de vernier l'etec mais ça
aurait été une faute de goût de faire ce
film mal se terminer
voilà on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai regardé tous les deux la caméra
vous allez dire magnéto sur seize cadres
rouges claude voilà hockey manille dont
doit aussi apprendre à manier toulon
mais dans un deux trois mais l'étau
s'est jamais si par exemple tu es de la
police un tu fais un coup main la poule
il ya une dame qui te demande de l'aider
dans la rue si cette dame par exemple il
te dit que on lui a pris son bébé city
américain je me la basse issue salle par
capita aussi des matelas gueule c'est
des gens il faut les décapiter vivant et
lapidé à coups de taxes et jean fête du
pâté du pape et
[Musique]
ce jour là j'ai toujours été attiré par
les pauvres
ce n'est ni mobile
ça n'arrête pas
alors de la crise les tiges de dieu
dentelle vous êtes dans tous ses films
dans bernie dans le dans le créateur
d'enfermer dehors et vous avez dit en
parlant de claude je préfère les grandes
actrices rare aux mauvaises très
fréquentes
ça j'étais sûr c'était journaux détails
qu'elle et lui plaît vous êtes un petit
peu l'homme de schaffhouse de demander à
qui pensez à kehl aux personnes c'est
vrai que je trouve qu'il avait clos ses
1 5% qui piaffent et j'aime bien
utiliser où il faut faire le mode
d'emploi donc voilà non messieurs
débouta tout ça c'est pas sérieux
thierry le film n'est pas sérieux je ne
suis pas sérieux rien n'est sérieux
voilà vous avez beaucoup vous dites son
animalité sa tendresse en même temps
mais ouais mais peut-être qu'elle peut
expliquer mieux que moi ça je t'en
penses de l'animal à une image peut-être
dans le sens où je suis plutôt
instinctive que cérébral en tout cas
pour le jeu
d'ailleurs dans la vie aussi sujets
phares j'ai faim de soif et voilà
pourtant au départ il a essayé pour une
actrice espagnole à votre place quand
même elle est morte
oui c'est vrai oui j'ai fait un contrat
contre elle ne faut pas déconner
s'est pas fait avec l'actrice espagnole
don légal est mort voilà donc il a il a
ramé pour vous pour vous re conquérir
auld en a chié l'état des comptes quant
à elle 12 voulait attendre longtemps
avant de dire oui j'ai pris mon temps
j'ai fait le tour du périph et dit non
non non non ça s'est passé comme ça tout
à fait donc il ya eu cette actrice
espagnole parce qu'il voulait en fait
pas et vous dirai mieux que moi ils
voulaient que ce qu'elle soit étrangère
pour accuser encore le fait qu'elle soit
perdue par rapport à l'administration
française et pour récupérer son bébé et
puis et puis donc elle était plus jeune
aussi pour encore le côté plus
vulnérables et donc il est resté encore
en pensée sur cette jeune personne dans
l'idée est donc petit à petit sous la
menace la torture il a fini par réaliser
qu'en fait il avait en face de lui
quelqu'un de beaucoup mieux des parties
une coproduction franco espagnole en
fait alors départ même avant ça c'était
un projet américain voudrait tenter
l'expérience américaine vous avez pensé
à robin williams et jake nicholls appels
du pied du cinéma indépendant américain
et en être vaniteux j répondu voilà
après un sursaut de lucidité de revenir
en france
ouais mais j'ai perdu un petit peu
tanger que j'ai croisé des personnes
très intéressantes et très présent tout
dire je vous dis qu ils sont marrants
comme ça le soir mais le lendemain on
est en face de leurs agents et c'est
déjà beaucoup
il ouvre les bras mais jamais je n'ai
donc c'est facile de manger avec eux de
s'amuser et c'est authentique mais dès
qu'on commence à travailler c'est
compliqué et puis surtout je pouvais
avoir ou pas je crois pas dans le
contrôle de mon travail ça me gênait
beaucoup quoi je suis revenu en france
précipitamment et j'ai reconstitué une
petite équipe derrière eux claude voilà
c'est beaucoup plus sage plus vous allez
passer quand même temps la barre je fais
des allers retours pendant 18 mois donc
à blanc elle vous n'êtes pas acharné
hollywood quoi non non non faut pas
alors le film s'est monté en france
n'est pas évident d'arriver à le monter
parce que c'est vrai que le créateur
s'est pas été un énorme succès non non
mais c'est ça c'est surtout une question
de
ne principal investisseur du cidem
enfance à la télévision et la télévision
est forcément friands de ce genre de
produits voilà gilles garnier jamais
passé en clair c'est si bête que j'ai
pas de l'audimat mais j'ai un score au
box office n'est pas forcément le bon
lundi masse est ou non mais c'est
logique aussi çà - doit savoir c'est une
partie du talent c'est de savoir se
vendre
il faudrait quelqu'un dit par avance un
film culte et derrière thuram pour faire
des trucs donc c'est pas toi je ne me
plains pas donc je connais les règles du
jeu ça vaut d'être malin vous vous dites
je m'ennuie souvent au cinéma surtout
avec sept postes nouvelle vague qui n'en
finit plus de mourir c'est que souvent
le cinéma à l'étranger français doit
être considérée comme la nouvelle vague
quand ils voient des signes qui ne
ressemble pas la nouvelle vague ils sont
surpris d'ici peu des sédiments flou
dans la cuisine puis avec partie parce
que karol arrivé quelques experts si on
a eu quelques quelques expériences aux
états unis qui était curieuse ce qui est
des gens venaient est sorti en disant
c'est pas du cinéma français donc on
était un peu embêté ont été inscrits
culturellement la nouvelle vague a fait
des dégâts malgré tout pour les petits
gars comme moi voilà c'est tout alors
c'est fini le one man pour toujours et
ça fait 15 ans qu'il va pas au truc quoi
non non non je mange ça me manque pas
voilà vous avez fait en fait des courts
métrages avant de faire des sketchs les
sketches et juste une façon nous faire
connaître
finalement c'est une porte qui s'est
ouverte et jean réussir est toujours les
gens comme sebastian bach à la
télévision parce que ces sketches
s'amusait beaucoup mes copains à l'école
de théâtre où j'étais chez vittel et
c'est vrai que c'était il ya 15 ans a
duré 18 mois et je me suis jamais
profité pour une carrière là-dessus avec
les sous du spectacle à ty anecdote j'ai
produit mon premier commettra saper le
désir etc et dans les bonus du dvd du
créateur et puis voilà ça s'appelle
avoir reçu de les idées et je succède
temps combret quelque part non pas du
tout sincèrement ça me frustrait puisque
jamais la caméra tout ce travail on a
souvent parlé donc j'aime bien cet outil
qu'est la caméra tout ça très beau très
souple ça me fascine à tora réseau j'en
sais rien ça me plaît beaucoup
la scène de frustré parce que je n'étais
que tout - seul sur scène tu as été
frustrant comme expression donc voilà
donc c'est juste ça on veut pas arrêter
par roger j'ai arrêté parce qu'il y
avait une femme plus belle qui
m'attendait voilà bien voilà enfermé
dehors donc sorti le 5 avril alors le
film le pitch comme je les dis c'est un
sdf qui enfile un costume de flic
alors on vous faire une interview si
vous étiez flics
si vous étiez plus que ce serait pour
quelles raisons non pas par nécessité de
manger voilà je pense un crs qui
s'énerve actuellement dans les manifs
c'est s'ils pouvaient faire de double je
crois qu'il le ferait ouais ah oui je
pense et ce quasi de pasolini et en 68
il a dû livrer prolétaires ce sont les
crs sans aller jusqu'à cet engagement
politique je pense sincèrement ça ne
m'agace il pouvait éviter de le faire
ils le feraient simplement on les
manipule alors leur fout sur la gueule
et les étudiants les flics c'est ses
trousses assez consternant comme
spectacle un jeune un flic qui se bat
avec un jeune en banlieue c'est un
pauvre qu'il y un pur et ça fait juste
quelqu'un qui manipule tout ce petit mot
sur sa totalement désolant quoi parce
que la personne qui voit sa voiture
brûlée à mettre dans la merde
par contre la personne qui ça profite
fera monter les cotisations d'assurance
et sa voiture sera jamais brûlé
puisqu'il évite pas même quartier donc
je trouve ça un peu désire vraiment anti
sociales cdc quand il s'est réveillé de
la compassion j'ai de la compassion pour
ces gens et je comprends les deux camps
je suis navré de voir le spectacle
la société actuellement de séjour de
droite et de gauche qui se font sur la
grotte ça me désole car il ya une chose
à [ __ ] dans ce pays 400 du lait a
priori ils ont toutes les compétences
requises ce qui n'est pas le cas
d'aurore nîmois d'oeil aux reins il
pourrait faire des choses là et on les
voit sont violées dans des débats
puérils et ça je trouve ça désolant
franchement toi ya beaucoup de gens dans
ce pays qui n'ont qu'une envie en fait
c'est que c'était trouver des solutions
parce qu'il a des problèmes mais là j'y
vais militer la classe politique est
absolument navrant j'ai presque eu le
sentiment que la masse ce qu'on appelle
la masse silencieuse de masse populaire
a plus de maturité région qui nous
dirigent j'en suis sûr regarde moi je
vote pas j'assume complètement
ils sont très disciplinés à chaque foyer
de me dire d'année non mais j'en remets
pouvez m'insulter doit donner ce que je
veux dire c'est que si je votais je vois
très blanc les votes blanc n'étant pas
validé en france du coup je me retrouve
un peu embêté parce que je me reconnais
aucun discours mais ce que veut dire
c'est que si le vote blanc est un il
était validée on pourrait être façon
pacifique intelligent influencer sur
démocratie je rejette ce candidat là je
rejette il est pas normal qu en 2002 on
est le choix entre le pire et le moins
pire et je veux dire c'est un grand pays
ce pays normalement c'est ce que
j'entends dire partout on a eu 30 % de
votes blancs et dont on aurait
recommencé les élections et c'est pas
plus mal jusqu'à ses des candidats qui
plaisent aux gens leur blanc avait de la
valeur que si le vote est obligatoire
il ya des tas de gens qui rêvent de
voter blanc de façon changer la règle du
jeu
oui si le vote est obligatoire le vote
blanc serait considérée beaucoup
quand nous commençons par donner le vote
blanc est en tout cas d'états gens iront
voter aujourd'hui le vote blanc donne là
une voie à donner sa voix au plus fort
malheureusement celle-ci tu votes sinon
je te dise il était valide constitution
loi n'existe pas le vôtre actuellement
six ont décidé que 15 ou 20 % de votes
blancs étaient ouverts invalider
l'élection des tas de gens je mettrai à
voter de façon à changer pacifiquement à
la règle et d'un jeu que personne ne
comprend actuellement c'est ce que je
dis actuellement vautier doit
effectivement revient pas faire
grand-chose à temps voilà bien un mot
quand on sait pas pour qui voter on peut
savoir si vous étiez petit qu'est-ce que
j'en mettrais le plus bas des techniques
non n'est pas des flics par contre les
flics c'est un boulot difficile et qui
n'a pas forcément la considération des
gens autour de soi quand il n'ya pas de
bons flics et de mauvais fixe et peut
avoir des effets mais qui sont en même
temps il ya des effets me tout d'un coup
il ya comme des mauvais supporters qui
les prend un par un ils sont gentils
sont entendues j'y reviens il ya quand
même des gros cons comme un peu comme
partout si vous étiez flics vous
arrêteriez qui en premier moi même voilà
pour éviter de faire des conneries tout
ce pouvoir et vous les sériephiles
équipe si vous étiez flic moi même
serons pas ma liberté
oui je connais qu'à travailler sur qui
si vous êtes ces flics personnes les
meubles feriez quoi comme bavure des
films donnant tout ce qui vous demande
de faire
voter blanc boy george tron aussi une
catastrophe
merci leur métier mais moi ça me ferait
plaisir ça c'est un bon voila voila j'ai
je me sens c'est pareil je me sens fier
les six joueurs sont fiers d'être
français voilà si c'est bien l'esprit
qu'il faut faire c'est infiniment du
fond du coeur voilà justifie gourrier
surtout avec quel accessoire nos
sifflets pour faire du bruit
tu sais que vous détestez auriez plus
les noirs ou les arabes
la connerie ce métier flics vous seriez
un peu excité chaque fois vous passer
des menottes à quelqu'un si j'étais tout
nu peut-être je sais pas j'aime essayer
tuner thieffry que j'utiliserai quelle
méthode pour faire parler les gens ne
votent blanc métier fait quel délit
laisseriez-vous impuni le les pétards
pas déconner quand même
le pétard oui les pétards faut qu'ils
arrêtent de nous emmerder c'est arrivé
vie paraît que c'est très dangereux un
coin infos sur deux il y avait un
rapport comme quoi c'était une drogue
douce ya deux ans puis maintenant c'est
très dangereux que de deux ans nous dira
j'ai moi même je me faut arrêter c'est
traîner jusqu'au prochain rapport
rester en vie soit d'ailleurs que le
dernier défi qu'est ce que vous seriez
amour et nicolas sarkozy je
démissionnerai
[Musique]